why do we launch rockets in Florida I
remember as a kid just not getting it as
I watched these rocket launchers get
scrubbed due to bad weather I was like
you guys know that's Florida right
that's where they get the hurricanes and
the thunderstorms and you know one of
the Apollo missions got hit by a
lightning strike on its way out of the
atmosphere it's unbelievable but there
are two very good reasons why they
launched Rockets from here the first is
because the ground beneath our feet is
moving to the east very fast everything
is going about 900 miles per hour that's
1500 kilometers per hour and that means
as your rocket takes off up and to the
east it starts off with that velocity
the Earth is giving that rocket an
initial boost so you don't have to put
in as much energy you don't have to
speed it up as much now the other thing
is if you're gonna fly to the East and
something goes wrong with that rocket
you're going to want it to not hurt
anything what's nice about Florida is
what you have over there is ocean not
the rest of your country